it's a Monday
yes it's me
you made it through the whole weekend
without me I know it's hard so anyone
here watch Real Housewives
and I don't mean the TV show
I mean actual Housewives through their
kitchen windows
I kid I would never do such a thing
would I maybe but the progressives at
the Working Families party are launching
their newest goal to radicalize the fans
of the Real Housewives franchise the
goal is to organize the fan base to
embrace woke beliefs
yeah how does that work how do you
organize people who believe a skinny
girl Martini is a healthy breakfast
organize it in the typical definition
it's not like helping you get your taxes
in order or Alpha alphabetizing your
record collection or placing your meds
on a shelf that cat can't reach
organized means radicalize which is
hilarious because the least organized
person on earth is a radical that's why
they boycott businesses instead of
running them
there's a reason looting doesn't start
at 7 A.M
but this is a new left-wing thing called
fandom organization in which groups
infest social media streams and litter
them with left-wing platitudes but it's
funny trying to radicalize people who
watch Real Housewives to do what exactly
that from now on you only throw
biodegradable wine glasses at each other
I don't think these guys watched
housewives in case
in case you have never watched Real
Housewives here's a taste prostitution
[ __ ] everybody
[Music]
oh my God
I love that so much but all that wasted
wine
Julie Banderas would be attacking them
with a sponge
[Laughter]
but maybe what really would help those
people is a strong dose of Communism
it's got to be cheaper than Botox watch
five minutes of those shows and you'll
think maybe the Taliban has the right
idea
I don't mean that for a second
maybe so how will they vocify the wives
these are women who think following the
science means another facelift
and they already dress like drag queens
but the left are going to build a
following on their Instagram Pages
create memes and reels that connect the
Real Housewife fans with Progressive
politics and only progressives could
come up with that mismatch take
something shrieking mindless loud and
stupid and then pair it up with the Real
Housewives
foreign
but this is necessary given the
Housewives Are Rife with white supremacy
true according to the Huffington Post
where writers are as dumb as a post they
cite as proof that a housewife's friend
once used the okay sign and that is not
okay because it's a white power symbol
tell it to these folks here huh
that's the best part
it's best part of white supremacy you
get to hang out with all these amazing
black people
but what about people who just want to
watch their favorite trashy show without
getting clobbered with Clumsy stupid
woke
well you're part of the story you're
part of the problem because everything
changed with evil Donald Trump once he
won in 2016 people could now ask others
who they voted for and it was a moral
crime if you admitted to backing the
orange Godzilla your private choices
were now open for public condemnation
and it went from voting to vaccines
which created more busy bodies than
antibodies
I like this audience
it's like they're sampling soup
in every facet to life things took a
political turn meaning when lefties lose
an election then they come after you
politics is now more personal than your
hygiene and because the woke are
miserable they need to spread the misery
everywhere they don't have a life
outside of politics they are for the
most part sour unhappy smug little
creeps who were that way in high school
so as adults they hung out with
like-minded people to fill the void in
their miserable personal lives thus the
Progressive Movement was born and now
like corn syrup they want politics
integrated into everything they believe
every single part of life is open to
political influence as long as it only
comes from them now it's in schools
sports and entertainment and now they
want to Target fan bases I'd like to see
this spread see how it goes you know try
NASCAR because there's nothing a Nascar
fan loves more than a good education on
race and lgbtq issues
yeah while they're watching an actual
race
those cars may make nothing but left
turns but the fans certainly aren't
going to hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
bottom line people watch the housewives
as trashy escapism and political crap
bleeding into those shows would only
ruin it
oh hi Becca I'm so surprised to see you
here tonight I thought you'd be at home
reviewing the Q3 GDP reports from the
Bureau of economic analysis excuse me
[ __ ]
why would Denise say that she knows the
strength of the US dollar can influence
midterm elections especially when it
pertains to the European markets oh this
coming from the [ __ ] who routinely
overestimates the employment rate poor
well at least I'm still married to my
belief in representative bicameral
legislature whatever
um
Sharon
she is a nightmare I heard that she
thinks the Constitution was created and
ratified on the same day
myself
let's welcome
tonight's guests
he's produced more cheers than your
local pet Squad TV Rider and producer
Rob Lowe
she breaks Southern stereotypes like a
southerner breaks chickens Nets Fox
Business anchor Tegan McDowell
[Music]
this Halloween he's going as a
successful husband and father
actor writer and comedian Jamie listow
and for trick-or-treat she'll be handing
out Tide Pods Fox News contributor
tattoo
no I didn't realize this raw but you are
actually the original model for the
world's happiest hobo yeah I am
it's uh yes I'm the world's happiest
hobo and I have told you I have
described you and print recently as a
giggly Pepper Pot I feel that way it's
like what about my weight no no just
your whole vibe oh wow that's great
spicy yeah I guess that's okay not okay
actually but it sounds good
now you're in the entertainment world uh
is this a wise move
no it's never wise to uh first of all
it's not wise for two reasons never wise
to take something really uh trashy and
amoral and try to load some other
meaning onto it it's always a mistake
but also like um you know there they are
ambulatory psychotics these Real
Housewives and so now they're going to
do it they want to do something with
Mary ambulatory psychotics with a you
know television show about politics we
already have that it's MSNBC it exists
nicely done you don't ever try to do two
things at once yeah that's true be funny
to pull the reverse and then embed like
kind of left wing areas with common
sense what do you think of that hobo man
well I have to set down my bindle and
think about it yes but yeah I feel like
that could uh that no that would it's
what's the why are you doing that it's
like yeah it's like it's like you it's
like I'm gonna have a a a pizza and a
salad no they're not gonna have the
salad that's a great have the junk Foods
you're gonna have enjoy it that's a
great way dagger do you watch these
shows or do you live these shows
oh I love these shows yes but I admit
that because I'm of an age where I don't
need a man and I don't want to get laid
um
because if you're talking to a potential
hookup or get down about the Real
Housewives that's like saying I haven't
washed my nether region since Labor Day
actually I water it means back but
anyway go ahead
eye-watering body odor is less repellent
than talking about my favorite housewife
when you're on a on a date but I view
this this is the worst match of a
left-wing liberal group with a series
shows that display
conspicuous consumption and riches
instead like instead of like the Working
Families party this is the how to find a
rich old coot who's about to kick it
party yeah
I feel like this show is the opposite of
that we are injecting drinking gossip
and stupidity into politics I think it's
worked but you are a rich old coot about
to kick it yeah in that sense you bring
it together he's not close enough give
me a couple of years I'm lucky Jamie
take me from this cruel world oh well I
agree with digging I don't need a man
either
[Applause]
but but I want a man yeah you're right I
disagree with the second part
um I've never seen this a minute of this
show a second of the show until you just
played it dude what do they do when
there's no cameras yeah
they murder each other
what was that was insane I don't need to
watch stuff like this if I want to watch
something like this I could just picture
scenes from the last few years of my
marriage
it's true my other thing is I don't um
there are a couple things but it's like
I don't know I I think it's weird I did
kind of wake up this morning like man I
wish there was one more reason not to
watch The Real Housewives I didn't feel
like 11 was enough
um isn't it crazy though it's on this is
on the Bravo network if this becomes a
series it will be on Bravo Bravo means
like something you want more of and
you're excited about this should be on a
network called Boo
or maybe boo plus yes boo Plus
because that's the opposite of Bravo
let's see what he did there Ah that's
comedy my friends hi Kat how are you I'm
great good good you had a long day today
flying back from Denver yeah I went to a
concert last night yes and it was in
Denver
that's great yeah good for you do you
are you worried that this could detract
from the enjoyment of this highly
sophisticated brand I know that you're a
regular Watcher I don't actually not
this one I don't watch this one but I
actually did some research in this group
they they say okay we are pretty
anti-capitalist in parentheses which we
know yeah isn't for everyone
which is true and I bet the top of that
list would be women who are on a show
because they're so rich and so obnoxious
about it yes like I've never watched it
but I was going through like some of
what the most famous quotes and catch
phrases are I did not have to scroll
very far before I saw I am very rich
[ __ ]
sounds pretty capitalist to me well I
guess you could argue that maybe they're
the ones that need most of this
education I don't think they're
interested no I don't think so either
you know I I zoned out I don't know
oh you are the world's sweetest hobo
you know what just for that you get to
sleep in my shed oh wow what would
happen if you were mad at me
nice drunk Real Housewives mean drunk
yeah that's true that's true hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else